taclant à face tacchelli parce qu'elle
est célibataire et julien alors on lui a
demandé par exemple une soirée
romantique pour vous c'est quoi c'est
une soirée avec votre moitié très
cocooning un dîner au restaurant ou du
sexe du sexe et encore du sexe à la dîme
soir avec votre moitié très cocooning
qu'est-ce qui peut important dans un
couple la fidélité la complicité le sexe
la fidélité à la patrie le sexe donc
c'est bon pour vous maxime évier ou
celui qui est alors celui qui se
rapproche le moins je vous le dis on a
vu je crois que c'est celui qui se
rapproche le moins de kelly voilà en
sixième position
celui qui a la main basse et mathieu de
la merde en cinquième giuly s'est très
vite allez on va pas faire rester de
gilles quatrième celui qui est le plus
compatible et kelis et julien troisième
jean-michel deuxième mais non au premier
damana camille vaz maintenant mais cela
ce qu'on va vivre la mission s'ils font
des bébés se lasser des norvégiens
cela c'est leur fils et non pas du
saumon fumé au moins des blinis au moins
des finances nous voilà donc vous avez
très bas très heureux mais je suis déjà
en couple c'était le 5 mars
merci à maxime et déjà pris ou qu'il
vous reste lui reste plus court donc je
le dis c'est pas pris part qu' il est
pris par sa tête